senior national security contributor
Mike Morell was acting and deputy
director of the CIA with us now from
Washington
Michael Emmett began with this from what
you know what stands out most in this
tragic attack Charlie I think it's
really important to put this in context
into roughly the size of the Brussels
attack
it's the largest attack in Europe in ten
months since nice and it's the largest
attack in the UK in 12 years so it's the
it's the size of the attack it's the
significance of the attack that I think
is important here what about the
location so Nora
whoever did this was was very
sophisticated in the both the location
and the timing the location was a place
as you know where there's a large group
of people exiting and the timing in
terms of the end of the concert more
people flowing out mass together at the
end of a concert than the beginning of
concert so whoever did this was very
conscious of how to maximize casualties
so Prime Minister may told us this
morning that they know the identity they
believe they know the identity of the
suspected bomber and there's been an
arrest of a 23 year old man what are the
next steps here and no one has claimed
responsibility yet Mike right so Gail we
we still don't know whether he acted
alone or he had accomplices one of the
things you'll see in the aftermath of an
attack is the arrest of any friends who
might have known him who might have been
in contact with him just to find out
what they know there's also probably the
arrests of other people they've been
watching and who are worried about who
they fear may be triggered by by this
attack is it like a copycat fashion is
it likely someone could carry out this
attack alone Charlie yes unfortunately
on the internet you can find
instructions detailed instructions on
how to build a bomb like this so
unfortunately yes it is possible for
somebody to do this on their own so you
don't care me this morning described the
unimaginable worry of parents and
relatives what about secure
here in the United States so our venues
like this whether they be concerts or
sporting events you have considerable
security you have to go through metal
detectors we still don't know what the
requirements were in in Manchester I've
heard different stories but our security
is pretty good but I think the important
point Noor is that there is always there
is always a seam right there is always a
place where security ends and that's
what this bomber struck and that's
always possible here as well all right
Michael Morell thank you so much